außerdem haben sich drin man bei max wir
müssen im schnitt ist noch größer als er
selber herzlich willkommen wir reagieren
heute auf den schnitt und bewerten auch
den schnitt von drei lecks vor allem am
start ich persönlich suche übrigens ein
kater der mir vier bis acht stunden die
woche aushelfen kann also wenn du gut
schneiden können bock drauf hat diesmal
die beschreibung des und alle import von
getreide und zwar bewährt sich das ganze
in verschiedenen kategorien und zwar
qualität musik und sound ließ das tempo
und am ende zur einschätzung der schnitt
dauert etwas machen wollen
juli los ist er okay wir haben ja schon
mal - auf jeden fall sehr schön junge
das thema musik drin man 3 max mir
persönlich fehlt es ein bisschen aber
natürlich geschmackssache
das persönlich habe ich nicht mag dann
ist es auch nicht schlimm ist mir zu
brutal
eine coole melodie mit mir persönlich
schon gefallen habe ich gesagt das ist
natürlich geschmackssache
du kannst münzen einsammeln
also kein nachteil durch ausgestorben
ist und da war auch der verzerrung
defekt am start
ich habe bisher ehrlich gesagt noch nie
ein video von trainings gesehen aber ich
glaube das ist gar nicht so schlecht um
kann ihr video zu stellen hier ein
schöner übergang ich bin an sich ist das
video nicht mehr aufwändig oder negativ
geschnitten aber es gibt auf jeden fall
cool das ist wahrscheinlich genauso
geschnitten wie er sich das vorstellt
wir sind so langsam und mir fehlt auch
um ehrlich zu sein die musik ich weiß
dass es auch geschmackssache aber mir
fehlt die persönlich einfach ich finde
dass wir noch mal unterhaltsam mal wenn
da ein bisschen musik jetzt mit der
grund war vor allem um diese langen rede
pausen jetzt hier ein bisschen zu
überbrücken
also dass mangel dass man andere sind
natürlich diese unruhigen 1000 und
szenen und lustigen face und lustig
keiten von crytek ziemlich gut hervor
ich glaube noch mal ein anderes wieder
an ich kann mir eigentlich irgendwie
nicht vorstellen dass du dass der junge
keine musik hat ich meine dass videos
witzig keine frage aber ich komme wieder
dennoch so ein cooler wisch effekt das
geht auch nicht zensierte förderer ganz
interessant wie muss ich dir nämlich
analysieren geschafft ich bin auf den
winkel an das leichteste unter anderem
ich finds echt
also ich bin mega unterhalten versteht
mich nicht falsch ich werde ich das
video ist es trotzdem lustig aber mir
persönlich fehlt er die musik mit
persönlich fehlen da die parade pause
noch ausmachen könnte ich verstehe
natürlich auch einige menschen gibt die
das einfach geil finden wenn das so ist
und der auch mir persönlich aber meine
persönliche einschätzung die fans
bisschen zu leicht zu lesen also der
erfolg gibt ihm recht zu verstehen nicht
falsch aber ich persönlich langweilig
nicht anzusehen
ich verstehe aber nicht wieso keine
musik reinmacht okay das war wie bei
geiles mim
die minsterin sind die sind auf jeden
fall nahe ist und in der kategorie mir
doch immer punkten
die kategorie musik und bekannte story
tempo oh/da weil er keine musik hat und
ich persönlich mir persönlich für mich
persönlich muss musik in dem
youtube-video drin sein außer ein paar
stellen wo man es halt ohne musik aber
presse rüberbringen oder wo der der
mangel an musiken besonderen effekt hat
aber ansonsten das ist einfach musik und
sehr wichtiges element meiner meinung
nach um emotionen zu übertragen oder um
eine geschichte besser zu erzählen oder
einfach um eine bessere lustige stimmung
zu transportieren
aber man braucht einen moment war doch
keine sekunde mindestens eine sekunde
das ist echt freundlich zu mir los ist
ein schnitt ist noch loster als er
selber nach einer drache besiegt völlig
überfordert klingt auch auf jeden fall
sehr sehr witzig wir schauen mal daran
was mich interessiert hat der mann einen
kater guck mal ganz kurz rüber ich ich
könnte ja vorher schon da sagt kain hat
um ehrlich zu sein aber sogar karten
katar der alle marvin okay das ist jetzt
ein kalter schauer über den vorbei auf
instagram überrascht mich tatsächlich
ein bisschen ich meinen max max max max
max den jungen einfach nicht gut im
griff du müsstest du mal öfter im keller
einsperren sowie das immer bei mir
gemacht haben keinen bock zu schneiden
hatte was das nicht noch mal sprach kein
spaß wir wollen jetzt endlich zum
beispiel the witcher da steht jetzt wäre
zum beispiel eine gute gelegenheit
gewesen heran zu suchen und dann so ein
sound einzufügen hätte man hätten wir
noch ne dann fällt die musik da ist
einfach
und vorne könnte man dann am ende auch
hier rede pausen könnte man wegschneiden
leute könnte man kann und muss man aber
natürlich nicht denn es ist natürlich
traurig schnitt und der erfolg gibt wie
gesagt recht die leute feiern in die
leute fahren seine videos leute kaufen
sich dann auch seinen schnitt wenn er
das möchte und sein kater dann ist es
auch perfekt also ich sage nicht dass es
schlecht ist wie sie das machen das ist
optimal also wie gesagt das passt auch
gut zu dem noch persönlich würde einfach
ehrlich gesagt anders machen jetzt auch
nicht schlimm wie vor ich jetzt eine
ehrliche abschätzung darüber abgeben wie
lange oder wie kurz der mal wieder dran
schneidet das hätte ich mir erst ein
paar fragen und zwar welche emotionen
muss das ganze aus also ich finde das
ist einfach möglichst nah dran an der
gaming experience die er auch hart es
ist einfach so wird man ihm dabei
zugucken wir gerade box oder bei einem
film zu gucken
das ist wahrscheinlich auch so
beabsichtigt und die leute fahren das
kann die authentizität wie passt das
schnitt zu zwei max ist es gar nicht
aufgesetzt das passt natürlich
kompletter schnitt hebt einfach genau
remakes art von max ehrliche und
unverblümte art wie er quasi an spielern
geht auch sich nicht in der salons in
den game und er versteckt sich da auch
gar nicht davor das macht ihn einfach
sympathisch deswegen stützt der schnitt
das natürlich ganze sehr sehr gut und
auch wenn ich persönlich das video an
schneiden würde passt er schnitt
trotzdem so gut zum 26 und deswegen ist
das doch alles was man braucht dann ist
es angenehm anzugucken
für die meisten wahrscheinlich schon ich
persönlich finde diese langen pausen
bisher nicht unangenehm aber da fehlt
aber rast also zumindest mal musik wäre
für mich angenehm wie aufwändig war der
schnitt er nicht so wie man auch
eigentlich sieht da ich nicht musik dran
da sind nicht so viele ministranten zu
ein paar und zwar ein paar sehr gute
aber nicht mega viele es wird nicht oft
ran und rausgesucht
es gibt keine vielen schnitte zur
qualität sieht man jetzt gerade hier an
dem bild ist ordentlich also kann man
auf jeden fall nicht wirklich besser
machen bei den youtube und co oder der
dass er sowieso sehr sehr unterschreibt
die qualität von zehn dann musik und
sound muss ich einfach nur eins von zehn
geben jetzt haben wir nur zwei von zehn
beiden lebensjahren cooles an sobald der
mangel an musik stört mich persönlich
vielleicht nicht aber für mich
persönlich ist es nicht mehr als zwei
prozent an ihm ist bei - gibt es zehn
von zehn teams die dritte fand ich
richtig neu ist es nicht schade dass der
mann nicht mehr davonrennen machen kann
auch sein dass es einfach zeitlich nicht
drin ist ist ja auch nicht schlimm der
pc-hersteller den tag zwei videos raus
kann ich voll verstehen plattform
schnitt tempo der g bis 5 und 10
und zwar weil es mir persönlich viel zu
langsam ist aber ich natürlich auch weiß
dass es gewisse atmosphäre hervorrufen
deswegen kann ich sage nicht weniger als
5 von 10 geben so jetzt zuschnitt dauer
man kann natürlich nie genau wissen habe
ich gehe mal davon aus dass der karte
einfach von tri mainstream
ich weiß nicht genau wie lange die
extreme vielleicht zwei drei stunden
ungefähr und daraus das spannendste
stelle oder einfach ein paar highlights
kann ich mir genauso vorstellen
geil also die minis und die effekte die
credits die sind auf jeden fall geil
aber treu mix bietet so viele
möglichkeiten die lustigkeit noch
auszuarbeiten einmal heran zu zoomen
sein gesicht zu verzehren mal einfach
wenn du musik hass und wenn er sich dann
dumm verhalten kannst du die musik
ausblenden und dann ist es noch lustiger
weil der mangel an musik hat einfach
dass man ja vorher auch wenn es
natürlich trotzdem voll nachvollziehen
kann warum eine summe ich würde sagen
auch da details kann halt einfach nicht
größer und nicht kleiner wird da die
schnitte nicht sehr zahlreich dass wir
nicht jede redepause rausgeschnitten
jedes m wird nicht weggeschnitten werden
bringen gelassen
dadurch ist es so ein relativ flott
nicht wenn man behaupten dass ich so ein
video innerhalb von anderthalb stunden
wenig geübt in wahrscheinlich sogar eine
stunde starten könnte kann auch sein
dass er länger braucht kann das land
eine andere software benutzt kann auch
sein dass er noch nicht so da gestaltet
kann auch sein also sie noch nicht mit
diesen ganzen shortcuts
auseinandergesetzt hat mit denen man
eben schneller wird wenn er die lernen
möchte kann übrigens ein schnittkurs in
der video beschreibung
aber ich persönlich wird zum video in
einem bis anderthalb stunden schneiden
muss aber auch sagen dass ich komplette
flick bin was makros und bots angeht ich
mir selber programmiert haben dass noch
viel schneller zu machen was aber die
meisten menschen wahrscheinlich nicht
gemacht hat also der schnitt ist meiner
meinung nach ausbaufähig aber bei dem
trax dem cutter und offensichtlich seine
community dass er sowieso gefällt dann
ist es natürlich perfekt wenn das so ist
wenn er den schnitt von heute auf morgen
umgestellt werden würde würde ich mir ja
viele leute sagen nee das gefällt mir
nicht dass es so schnell ist und so
weiter und so fort deswegen kann ich
voll verstehen dass wir das so machen
wenn ihr euch wie schneiden
interessierten die beschreibung ab da
ist ein schnittkurs talente schreiben
und wenn ich auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte dann abonniert gern main kanal
und dann sehen wir zunächst mal wieder
ganz gut
[Musik]